and breaking right now at 6 30 our
i-team getting the 9-1-1 calls in the
amari nicholson murder case
amari's mother's boyfriend accused of
killing the two-year-old the i-team's
david charns joining us from the
newsroom
with more now david yeah brian denise
samari's mom taylor calls 9-1-1
twice the day amari was reported missing
she told a dispatcher terrell rhodes the
man accused of killing amari
had told her that a family member on
amari's father's side
came to their apartment and took him
it's something that terrell told
our own reporters here's part of that
phone call
ma'am who has your child i don't know
i was my boyfriend showed that a lady
was knocking on the door this morning at
6
and said that she was my baby daddy's
sister
and said that she was there to pick him
up that everything was already
pre-pre-arranged and
i spoke to nobody so
they came in and took him and ran out
the door with him
and so i don't know if it is his sister
if
it's some a total stranger i don't know
now taylor also asks about an amber
alert but the criteria for that wasn't
met since there was no suspect or
a car description in reality police say
no one took amari and terrell rhodes
killed him concealing his body
you can hear these calls right now
they're about 20 minutes long you can
hear them on eight newsnow dot com also
inside our free app
live in the newsroom i'm david charns
eight news now